[Music]
have you guys heard about the four
states that are reopening businesses
over the next two weeks or no it's
probably the south yeah listen they want
to be free stop taking their freedom
Steve got represent his people a matter
of freedom Steve it's life and death
oh yeah light for who I'm living is this
you from San Diego or Virginia that's
that I've been all over I flew all over
this land
I feel like though the media is kind of
spinning it on these people like getting
the craziest [ __ ] because some of
them do have a legit like argument about
going back to work or whatever but then
they always highlight the craziest
[ __ ] get the south will rise
again guy yeah what the big [ __ ]
rebel flower yeah we're coming we are
coming so you guys would say to see 450
years man and then all the other
protesters were like who the [ __ ]
invited Bob man and then the news goes
up and [ __ ] interviews him instead
what's going on he said oh yeah we're
coming back you'll see yeah there's the
people that are like I'm tired as [ __ ]
can't keep my freedom and they're
showing up with guns too so now that
they're tying in like the community that
I like right but then now you're giving
that committee another bad name because
now they're tying two different
communities together I'm like Oh cuz
they invited Bob Wow yes Georgia South
Carolina Texas and Tennessee they have
announced plans to allow some businesses
to open their doors within the next
couple weeks and then recently with
Trump's like with Trump's guidelines for
opening up America again they there were
some bolded names in that list and that
included restaurants movie theaters
places of worship and gyms so even
though it's not California well it's a
win for you those are all the areas that
can get affected the most people are
breathing super hard yeah
yeah has a lot of disease exactly so a
lot of people are really concerned with
with all this like hope that's that the
country will reopen again because then
it's leading to a lot of people
believing that there will be a second
wind of things like there's just gonna
be a whole lot more depth advantageous
plan where they chose like the most
populated places to be phase one I think
the states are choosing yes
the states are choosing I know cuz they
should go in like South Dakota and
Wyoming
it doesn't reason while like areas that
have less people we're gonna open up the
orgy centers first I get behind is
pointing somehow turned into like a
partisan thing that's what's a Jo the
most conservative states are opening up
first because they're like yeah this is
not a big deal you guys are just
pretending it is right somehow this has
turned into a like a party oh that's why
I like even though the protests are like
people are saying when you come to these
protests are protesting the lockdown it
feels more like a trump rally than
anything else yeah it's all political
now it's political both sides to man
because because you've got people on the
Left who are saying let's just stay home
forever forever get the 2000 I was over
on Twitter like so it's like and I feel
what the worth about is that we all got
tricked into thinking that we got
there's some kind of help that happened
like there's no help from our government
like they gave everyone twelve hundred
bucks and they said hey we might reopen
in six months or five months so a lot of
people are [ __ ] and they can't they
can't wait for maybe maybe we'll do
another stimulus or something like so
they're like I have to work I have to do
something so this these people were
forced on the streets with desperation
yeah like the idea that we can all just
haha [ __ ] these [ __ ] meth heads and
[ __ ] is is it's [ __ ] mean frankly
because we're not we're not factoring in
what they're going through probably
financially probably fear wise like so I
don't I don't have a problem hope I have
a problem with people who are like hey
[ __ ] these people and all this [ __ ] and
not thinking about what they're going
through like I wonder what the whole
reason for the armed
armed resistance was because yeah so no
where where guns in public I feel like
because it was like was it Texas they
all stormed like City Hall and it's
[ __ ] no it's a big like gun rally
slash quarantine protest in inside of
like a government building just [ __ ]
armed to the teeth and all it's just
like don't turn this in a Waco I'm like
how the foot okay I just didn't see the
connection between that in the whole
maybe they're just conflating you every
X tres that they're feeling at the
moment you know from sure from politics
to quarantine to to to their individual
desires of owning guns and whatnot you
know and they're just like I'm just a
vet right now every time we give you
everything I got right now well when you
turn on the TV and people who make
$30,000 a week do being anchors and [ __ ]
are telling you that you're [ __ ]
idiot and should stay home and you're
like I don't have any money I think the
problem is that there isn't an easy
answer no matter what absolutely right
there's there's no good answer of when
you're supposed to come back and when
when you should when how long we should
hold this out for because this there's
some things that the experts say which
is like okay we need to wait like a
certain amount of days but when that
will happen we don't know and when that
does happen how do we ease back into
normal society right but all the experts
American yeah they they asked him like
what are you gonna do after this cuz
like with the mortgage payments and
people who need a pay rent are they just
gonna have to pay everything back later
and I think at least for that interview
he answered it well in which he says he
doesn't know because I is the worst one
either like oh yeah I have the answer
but when you don't have the answer cuz
no one know that one's trying to figure
it out talk to the experts tops of the
economies to trying to see what kind of
bills they can pass to make it like not
life destructive after we survive this
thing and the experts on the dark -
right like as information slowly was
filtering out they're trying to create
like a tapestry for
what we're gonna do because all the
information kept changing because China
was being very secretive evolved with
all the outbreak stuff so there's so
much things happening in real-time and
everyone's just trying to play catch-up
and then also at the same time we did
this huge [ __ ] stimulus package if you
were to take all that money and just
give it to the people who are [ __ ]
right now everyone would've got like 20
grand and the idea that that's a lot of
it that's a huge safety net yeah the
idea that we just took care everybody
because we gave him 1,200 bucks and said
a good luck is [ __ ] up and not well
more than half went to the financials
exactly went to the top thousand [ __ ]
companies and top thousand richest
people in America so people can [ __ ]
blow me about how oh look at all these
[ __ ] simpletons on TV like well it's
just another way of divide and conquer
right cuz it's it's like hey look at
these idiots I mean it's funny to watch
them of course but it's so fun I dunno
where that kind of thinking stems from
though like people that are thinking
that it's fake or people that are
thinking that you know they're it's way
blown out of proportion you won't really
get sick and all that stuff because
there are actual doctors and people that
are coming out saying like hey this is
manufactured like this it's all
conspiracies yeah but there's there's
one guy that's lately manufactured it's
what you're talking about right in wuhan
right well it's not a conspiracy well
they don't know where it's manufactured
from but there are scientists that are
researching it and saying that this is a
man-made bioweapon and it's from
legitimate scientists one was the guy
who he didn't invent aids but he
discovered aids with the team and he's
saying that yeah this this this virus is
basically man-made well it's not
man-made it's it's altered and I thought
I saw this on CNN it was um it was a so
we talked about this two months ago
intaking is about how there's a there's
a conspiracy theory about how the the
virus originated in this lab in Wuhan
and it was spread to the population I
thought came from yummy bets
yummy
no so apparently there was a there was
an intern who had contracted coronavirus
and they were like patient zero and they
they spread it somehow in that area two
miles away from that lab and that's
where it came from and this yeah I just
saw it on a bunch of does it have
anything to do with bats I have no idea
there's the wet market bat conspiracy
and there's like the conspiracy of it
like what they're working on bats in a
lab I'm sorry no bats involved it's just
they're working on a virus it's just all
over the place the hard thing is trying
to figure out something that has already
happened right it's like any time you
study like ancient history right it's
like you look at all these little points
of evidence you're like I think this
connects this way but can anyone ever
really really know like they can get 90%
of the way there and hope that they're
right yeah it's just correlation they
can't prove cause yeah and even a year
from now we'll know way more yeah I mean
every day we're learning a little bit
more right that's crazy but the
government's definitely well not just
the government but the people with mad
power they're using this as a really big
advantage on their play because the way
that the money works is they can print
out the money and then be get first dibs
on on grabbing that it's the same thing
when they pass the Patriot Act right if
you came out against the Patriot Act
you're against America and you're for
the terrorists if you remember if you
can think back that far that's exactly
what they did in the media the Patriot
it's like a massive surveillance I could
tap off those right they can telephones
that can [ __ ] spy on you they can get
a bench warrant and they can they can
spy I can spy on you really easily and
openly you know how Snowden came out and
I was against the Patriot Act the
Patriot is the reason why NSA was a-ok
they were allowed to spy on us yeah it
just it was the green light and then but
then back then there was congressman
throws one Dennis Kucinich who came out
and he said I'm not voting for this and
they all [ __ ] all over his head you're
too good at remembering people's name
managed dennis kucinich how do you
remember a name like is a really known
politician though is that you're
immediately more credible because you
know a name thank you very much
something's completely wrong but you got
the name right or the year either on Bob
Newhart voted for it Bob knew her all
right now he's making a name with it
Peter Dinklage sick Peter D was again
names Tim wait where's Peter Dinklage
from game fun all right
I was like yeah he's very pretty
credible i bacteria always real name
right
[Music]
[Music]